[singing] Oh, the shameless
witch is dancing.
[singing] Oh, the shameful
fairy lies and gossips.
CUSTARD: Erica...?
You haven't ever wished
a family would adopt you,
have you?
Nope.
EARWIG: Anybody who’d choose me
would be pretty unusual...
[gasps]
We'll take this one.
What?
EARWIG: For the first time in my life,
I’m being made to do something
I don’t want to do.
Now then let's you and I
get a few things straight.
My name is Bella Yaga, I'm a witch.
Great!
You agree that you'll teach me magic,
and I agree to help you out!
BELLA YAGA: If you work really hard,
I shan't do anything to hurt you.
[gasps]
EARWIG: A Love Potion
for the Boy Next Door?
All of these are pretty useless to me.
[grunts]
The spell I believe you're looking for
is somewhere towards the back...
Hang on. You actually talk!?
Of course I do, just not very often.
In this household...
there's one rule that's crucial.
BELLA YAGA: You must
on no account for any reason,
ever dare disturb The Mandrake.
Don't be rude.
[singing] Don't disturb me,
I'm here to say,
Huh?
EARWIG: Earwig?
THE MANDRAKE: A hole left by a witch
can only be filled by a witch.
I'll be learning magic, or so I was told.
Can't wait to start!